yeah welcome to this video playing DWG
six from the UK and yeah that's
something even they're already kind of
opening let's see what we transpose into
a hedgehog yeah with this line with
taking on Jeff over the night it's
somewhat somewhat unambitious black you
get some relatively easy game with this
as you can already see I think yeah I
can even play d5 now D 5 D 5 D takes you
for this as possible
and D take C form takes on f6 Bishop f6
that didn't Eve I've that see me
let's see it this is maybe an
interesting okay
he's playing something else entirely
it's also also probably better no no I
cannot play with this P SEC and I'm just
worse Wow yeah d5 was bad
my ideas to get a night to eat forums 95
24 playing a three okay that's that's
develop stuff here yet defiled was
really silly if I just played these six
I'm in excellent shape very unnecessary
but I just forgot that you can take yeah
but maybe this isn't it isn't so
terrible get Ruby for amongst others
I'll be five now at five but I can just
take you five
I can even play Knight c5 here
I will get it back Markham let's do that
BTech c5 b tech c5 this B - hanging he's
got no way to to not return the his yeah
but he needs to take I played 94
otherwise
yeah this is strange why allow me to go
to your forum just taking was fine okay
so now let's check probably a six and B
five to get get a group C for but I
can't play Roxy for anyway I can play
this anyway because of the long diagonal
he cannot he cannot take twice I mean
I've got the knife discoveries only
possibility maybe maybe he can take
twice and then answer with Quincy six
okay but yeah something you don't want
to calculate really okay and that's now
playing b5 and make sure that I have
this c4 nicely positioned him
okay
so but how do I actually make progress
here
hmm yeah night - 85
yeah not easy to to make any headway
they are nuts and I don't really think
it's it's a big big deal here it can
even take the exchange this is still a
pretty good compensation but how to how
to make any progress
covering d8 that's maybe I can retain
him a bit if you place Knight a5 I just
let him take the exchange but it doesn't
matter
hmm Queen she's probably not
maybe Queen a5 next
or what it can make like she played that
him
try to make some headway here activating
or don't I hope you cannot take its it's
just the gamble not sure maybe you can
take
now if it takes Queen d5
check
check
yeah it's about equal endgame feeling
again nowhere better
check just winning the porn
check time warning check check check
seconds check check check check mate
yeah yeah tough game I really don't know
okay he people say much
he played panties fought too
aggressively with King King see six know
after age four I'm better after if he
goes H for himself now it's nothing
nothing doing wrong but after that I'm a
better and winning a pawn I'm not sure
that I should win the game but it's it's
much better for black now probably it is
winning even check because this King is
cut off yeah I'm not quite sure maybe
why should still wrong but okay it's a
matter of seconds here
yeah but D 555 was bad wow it's really
bad news I need to let's take it back
here I just need to play a move like
these six and I have a perfectly fine
head shock with the LightSquared bishop
bishops exchanged this helps black
enormously because I simply have a
little bit more space and the light
squares are somewhat weak and white scam
so these kind of ideas later can get
important it's not black it's not better
but it's it's nice and it's an easy easy
hedgehog to play but I forgot that after
d5 yeah I was I got fascinated by this
idea and this is indeed working like
this
but I occur I just forgot that you can
take care first and this is really
really awful
well alright school thanks for watching